bribing people sucks and makes them not
like you and not want to do the thing
that you want them to do so if I say I
want you to do something and I say I'll
give you this cookie if you do it you're
less likely to want to do it because
then it feels really transactional but
here's what's interesting you can
literally just change the order that you
do stuff and get them to want to do it
so if you say hey here's a cookie it'd
be really great if you did this thing
people will a think you're an awesome
person and then be far more likely to
actually do this other thing you can be
far more influential by flipping the
order and giving first